THAT HAPPENED IN DURBIN,
COLORADO.
FIRST, THE GANG OF SIX BILL IS A
COMPLETE AND UTTER JOKE.
EARLIER IN THE WEEK, THE
PRESIDENT EMPOWERED
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS TO COME UP
WITH A BIPARTISAN DEAL TO
ADDRESS THE STATUS OF THE
800,000 OR SO DREAMERS THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA PROTECTED FROM
DEPORTATION AND REMEMBER, THERE
WERE SOME RERECOGNITION --
PREREQUISITE
PREREQUISIT
PREREQUISITES.
AND TODAY, UNVEILING THE GREAT
COMPROMISE.
WHEN I HEARD THAT THOSE THREE
WERE INVOLVED, I KNEW IT WAS
GOING TO BE BAD.
AND DICK DURBIN SAYS THAT THE
DACA CITIZENS GET CITIZENSHIP
AND CAN HAVE SPONSORSHIP AND
ADMIT THEIR ILLEGAL PARENTS AND
ONLY 1.6 BILLION IS GOING TO GO
A REAL BORDER WALL IS EXPECTED
MONEY AND DO NOT TELL ME THAT WE
DO NOT HAVE THE MONEY TO ENFORCE
OUR OWN BORDER.
THE BIPARTISAN PROPOSAL PLACED
THAT IS GOING TO HAMPER THE
THE VISA LORIES  IS GOING TO BE
TEMPORARILY TRANSFERRED TO THE
IMMIGRANTS.
THE STANDARD IS LOWERED FOR THAT
GROUP.
I SUGGEST THAT THE BIPARTISAN
GROUP SHARPEN THEIR PENCILS AND
RETURN TO THE TABLE.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO DO IT.
NO WAY.
NO HOW.
IT IS GOING TO LEAD TO MORE
IMMIGRATION AND SPIKE THE NUMBER
OF LOW SKILLED IMMIGRANT
WORKERS.
THIS IS A BILL THAT THE
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD RUNAWAY
FROM IT.
AND JUST LIKE IN 2007, 2015, AND
VOTE IN HIS HOME STATE DURING
THE PRIMARY
THE PRIMARIE
THE PRIMARIES
THE PRIMARIES.
YES, 1%.
AND LET'S FACE IT, THE
IMMIGRATION VIEWS OF FLAKE AND
GRAHAM ARE NOT POPULAR AND THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD NOT TIE HIS
GREAT POLITICAL FUTURE TO THESE
SINKING ANVILS.
THEY SHOULD JUST SINK HIM RIGHT
DOWN.
WHAT I HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR ON
MY SHOW THIS MORNING.
>> IT IS BUILT ON ILLEGAL LABOR
AND THERE IS A PLENTY TOOT OF
ILLEGAL LABOR.
HOLDING IT DOWN FOR THE
AMERICANS.
>> THERE IS SO MUCH GUN VIEPGS
AND THERE ARE SO MANY ILLEGALS
IN CHICAGO RIGHT NOW AND SO HARD
FOR ANYONE TO GET A JOB.
>> PEOPLE KNOW HOW HIGH THE
STAKES ARE RIGHT NOW AND THEY
ARE ALREADY LIVING WITH THE
RESULTS OF THE OPEN BORDER
POLICIES AND THEY ARE SUPPORTED
BY THE SAME POLITICIANS PUSHING
THIS BILL ON TRUMP.
AMERICA HAS BEEN COMPLETELY
TRANSFORMED CULTURAL,
ECONOMICALLY BY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND MS-13 IS STILL
PROLIFERATING AND NOBODY WANTS
I GUESS WE ARE BLEEPING THAT.